you brought up that department of
justice statement uh i saw james lindsey
and joe rogan talking about it it was
kind of convoluted in like two
paragraphs is that have you seen that
tim do you know what she's talking about
sometimes the department of justice let
me pull it up because i know is that
pertaining like a statement
defining who now is considered dangerous
oh yeah yeah yeah and they said like
anti-capitalists
and then yeah i think glenn greenwald
tweeted it's actually a while ago yeah
yeah and so they were like hey left
you've all cheered for this and
celebrated it's you and then they posted
the list and it was like anarchist and
anti-capitalistic you know are
considered violent dangerous extremists
and then there's like patriots or
whatever so it's like
yo look man they may like the fact they
can use antifa as useful idiots to to
wreak havoc and cause panic and destroy
things and they can rebuild
but rest assured they'll they will come
for antifa when it becomes convenient
for them or when antifa is truly
inconvenient or when they're done done
with them when they fulfill their agenda
when they got rid of everything else
they're going to be looking like the
nail for the hammer that they created
it's only a matter of time and the deep
intelligence state has the information
is track tracing and database and all of
these people we learned that they even
have drones that they're flying over
protests they have dragnet surveillance
telephone technology that literally gets
all the information from people's phones
at protests they have all of their data
they have all of their information they
have all of their networks and
why wouldn't they be collecting it when
of course you have the state that that
throughout history has been getting
really bad yeah so it was uh it was a
testimony before the senate and it was i
think matthew olson who is the
assistant attorney general perhaps he
said domestic violent extremists are
often motivated by ideology and personal
grievances we've seen a growing threat
from those who are motivated by racial
animus as well as those who ascribe to
anti-government anti-authority
ideologies
so this is anti-authority anti-authority
which is
kind of the basis for the entire united
states that's right yes we are
anti-authority that's like half our deal
at least weren't the ghostbusters
anti-authority too
but but is antifa pro authority i mean i
would say yes yes but do they think they
are so are they listening to that going
live and he also said he also said today
investigating and prosecuting domestic
violent extremists is one of our top
priorities on the front lines this is
only because there aren't enough white
nationalists and white supremacists they
have to cast they're going to short
supplies
yeah it has to be everything it has to
be whatever they can find they have a
budget for a resting descent they that
are going to that's right
in there they said like uh if you want
to criticize the government it may not
be considered terrorism because it's
considered first amendment protection uh
the word may it may not be considered
terrorism that was very confusing my my
friends in 20 years everyone's gonna be
like four and a half feet tall
androgynous holding hands with squeaky
voices and that's going to be humanity
because like they're just shaving off
the tall grass
everyone it's like it's eroding so
quickly you know the people don't
realize this but there's been several
cases that i've i've tweeted about
talked about where people have been
charged with hate crimes for speech or
for like
bordering on speech you know
there was a one case where someone took
a pride flag and then i guess they like
burned it and threw it in front of a gay
bar they said oh that was that was
hateful harassment or something like
that and it's like nobody was no one was
there no one watched it happen nobody
was directly harmed by it it's kind of a
dick move in my opinion the guy got
charged with the hate crime for doing it
i'm like that's kind of crazy you know
what i mean but that's that's where
we're we're moving and we're getting
there was uh uh
two people were running uh were they on
like the the the new york train the long
island railroad and they were shouting
things about foreigners and then threw a
beer can at someone and they were ah
throwing that beer can and saying that
now it's a hate crime and like you get a
very serious charge for that so they're
starting to incorporate hate speech into
you know making it illegal and a lot of
people 10 years ago were saying that you
know the goal of the left is to make it
so you can't hate speech would be
completely illegal there are many
proponents who have pushed saying that
it should be illegal and now we're
seeing aggravated charges on people for
you know speaking things that are
offensive
it has to be associated with a crime
though in the u.s whereas in other
countries like in canada what what was
the crime of throwing a rainbow flag in
front of a bar well they have to call it
a crime of some sort right right but
like arson burning property but it was
their property it was it was it was
someone bought a flag burned it and
threw it from the building and they said
it was like harassment so they make up
the crime to fit how they can turn it
into hate speech or something and what's
happening in canada and the uk already
with these existing laws is so worrying
i remember walking around in the united
kingdom doing interviews about uh you
know english people not having the first
amendment would they want to the first
amendment and i ran into a person who
had his whole life ruined was thrown in
jail had to face court proceedings
because he called someone a bloke right
and this person that he called the bloke
was someone that identified as something
else but because he did it offhandedly
he literally was was was sent to jail
shout out shout out to zuma to a bunch
of people shout out to zubi who said
okay dude it was okay dude that's what
he said and he got suspended on twitter
for saying it well or
megan murphy who said that jessica yaniv
was him
you know she i think she got banned for
saying yeah him that was her whole tweet
shout out to zubie for getting his visa
american visa he's gonna be around a lot
more now
nice job dude
uh sorry i just wanted to derail the
conversation yeah something now you got
to finish it
i missed the aclu 1.0 that's what we
needed right i missed that too what
happened did you change it
i can tell you what happened so when
donald trump got elected
they made a ton of money off of the the
muslim ban as it was called now it
included venezuela you know in some
other countries but you know the left
called the muslim ban and the aclu said
trump you can't do this it's
unconstitutional the interesting thing
was that the banning of travel from
these countries actually advice from the
obama administration but that doesn't
matter so everybody protests the aclu
announces they're filing a lawsuit to
stop this and then all the leftists are
like yeah and they sign up for the aclu
and the aclu is like we're making bank
baby and then charlottesville happened
and the aclu defended the right of unite
the right to organize and the and then
everyone said you made this happen you
defended it and they're like but we've
always defended free speech for everyone
and the left started canceling in droves
so they came out and said we're going to
reassess what free speech means
and now the aclu is the anti-civil
liberties union because in many many
cases they have come out overtly against
civil rights and i'm not
there was some sort of transparency
educational policy that was discussed
because there's a great idea this
transparency right and they're against
it
but here's the thing about this so
education is now a national issue
that's what the left wanted this whole
time they got it parents are super
involved in kids education that's what
the left has wanted this whole time
parents are saying let's have
transparency let's see what the syllabus
is that's all it is let's see what the
syllabus is before the year starts that
way we know what's going on that way we
can help our kids we can know what's
happening in their classroom we can know
what they're learning and for some
reason the teachers unions are all
against this they've been demanding for
decades parents we need more parental
involvement and now parents are like hi
we're here we'd really like to be
involved and they're all just like you
know what you know back off okay that's
just not safe for your kids it's just
not okay parents do not have a right to
be involved
and we all know why i just don't have
kids they have yours right like the was
it melissa harris perry did you guys see
that that was an older clip that
resurfaced yeah i think but it still was
chilling it was crazy she was saying
basically the kids are not
yours saying kids are not yours they
belong to all of us and we need to stop
thinking that kids belong it's like
parents you are saying that
you know who kids belong to their
parents especially when they get hurt or
any decisions need to be made but
everything they need to be indoctrinated
then they belong to everybody ever see
that meme where it's like it's the drake
meme where it's my and our and and so it
like it shows shows him like going like
that it'll say like you know my car and
then under it says our car and he's like
yeah so it's like my kids no our kids
all right it takes a village i love my
favorite one was our little pony
and like they put a cichlid hammer next
to it and everything yo these people
i don't know if communist is the right
word no it's not it's it's a because
look what people need to understand
about fascism and communism is that
these were ideologies of the early 1900s
we're in a new digital information age
and what we're experiencing is something
different maybe maybe you can call it
techno communism or you know
uh techno tech authoritarianism or
something but it needs a new word yeah
this is another thing james and joe were
talking about and i promise i'm not
gonna keep bringing it up but watch that
episode if you haven't seen it yet
about uh
geez i just got dude
technically about about how it's like
fascism and communism blended and it's
21st century it's new um what klaus
schwab's trying to do with blending
corporate corporations and governments
together is basically the definition of
mussolini's fascism that's what he
called it but it's so different now that
they can spy on everything and like cut
off bank accounts globally that it's
another kind of techno
it is
it's not necessarily communism it's not
necessarily fascism it is authoritarian
but the thing about fascism is that it
was
cultural enforcement communism was just
they just took over and they point guns
at you it was much more authoritarian
and they would steal food and it was
just like it was like
the whole system was one thing with
fascism
basically i was reading this uh article
about how the nazis weren't really
socialists but kind of were because
people often say oh it means national
socialist what would happen is that
they would go to a factory and say are
you producing for the war effort and if
the guy at the factory said no we're
producing for a demand they'd be like
why do you oppose our efforts and they'd
be like no no we'll we'll do it
basically cancel culture the idea that
if you didn't fall in line with with
cultural enforcement and cultural
enforcement is more powerful than
government so that's the thing about you
know the fascistic method
now i guess back then there was a big
dividing ideology the communists wanted
to erase culture they wanted to purge it
and wipe it clean and the fascists want
traditionalism so what we're seeing
today is techn authoritarian communism
or whatever you'd call it i don't know
it all boils down to the evils of
centralization and the idea that you
could control people from top down that
idea i think is one of the most
destructive ideas without throughout all
of human history and whatever you label
it whatever you call it it goes against
the basic principles of free humanity
and that of course is liberty and and
decentralization decentralization right
now if you look at a lot of problems in
this world could
solve all of them
in in in
in an extensive way that would reduce a
lot of harm and help a lot of people out
because it would stop the bastardization
of power that absolutely corrupts
individuals so i think that's one way
that we should start framing it and
looking at it because you know to have
this larger idea that that one person
one king should control your life and
your existence has already fallen by the
way wayside now the another idea that
hopefully progressively is going to be
destroyed is that a president or an
autocrat or a corporate head is going to
be controlling your life and i think the
more we move away from those ideas the
more we move towards freedom the more
humans will prosper and grow i got it
hear me out
what if you run for president
and when you win you get four years
you can run again for a second term
and if you if if you lose
or you complete a second term we execute
you
oh
interesting so then it's like logan's
run secret but but that means anybody
who wants to be president knows that
they're not going to actually be
benefited in the long term this is the
end you've decided because you you know
then you get someone who's in their 60s
and they're like i've lived a long life
i have some ideas and i think this is
the end for me i'm going to do a bunch
of things i think will make everything
better for you and then i'm out this is
like i'm actually i'm actually kidding i
don't really think we should execute
this it's gonna be like a star trek
episode where the guy who played uh
the guy who played winchester on mash
ends up falling in love with uh deanna
troy's mom do you remember that one
that's right and then it's a society
where at a certain age they just killed
just kill you
they have a big party or just like take
all their money away when you go to the
white house you're and you're broke
you're broken yeah actually actually
maybe maybe what we do is as soon as you
leave any public office
you will do term limits so every every
office will have like a year base so
like in congress it's two years so okay
you can run four times the senate you
can run twice it's still kind of long
you'll get 12 years and then the
presidency is two and once you're done
you lose all your possessions you get a
white jumpsuit and you go to the island
and then you just live in a community of
people who are past civic leaders and
you can never leave and you've chosen it
the problem with having four two-year
term limits is that they'll spend every
year running for the next term and waste
all that time no but if you lose you go
to the island and so on that island
jimmy carter builds all the houses
that's right
no no so listen if you if you run for
congress and win you're in for two years
and then you're like i'm going to run
again and then you lose to the island
but i mean i don't want them to spend
any time while they're in office
worrying about a re-election i want them
to be in run their term and then be gone
so two two two two two terms like one
eight year term is that too much years
to give that's a good point that's a
good amount one for one four-year term
or maybe two four-year terms one
re-election maybe but they'll spend two
years prepping their real estate but
congress is two years ago
giving congress
four years and two terms and then once
you're done the island you know what i
want to point out about there's internet
there so you can play fortnite and the
kids can talk another possibility is to
elect our pets to be politicians and i
bet they would probably do a better job
than all the politicians right
yes there you go caligula one of the
roman crazy roman emperors inbred young
gentleman made his horse a counselor i
believe and there's a small town i
believe in alaska that elected a cat to
be their mayor oh really yeah when i was
thinking about how the nazis would go to
these corporations and be like are you
with us and then they're like no and
then like then you're against us there's
the nuance in society i think that's
been lost or overlooked lately that you
don't have to be for against something
you can be neutral and that's usually
you are
99.999 percent of the time people are
neutral to the environment it's only you
don't have to take a side
and live like that make sure you live
like that but polarize you know so i
tweeted uh a a joke about capitalism
today i said capitalism was too
successful we have fat homeless people
now
so
there's there's several different layers
to this joke and i felt like it would
play well with everyone for people who
are pro-capitalists they'd be like wow
even our homeless people are eating too
much for the communists and the left
they're supposed to be like people who
eat too much still don't have homes
like it's supposed to play both ways but
it's only the left who gets mad about it
the right just laughs and they're like
whatever and the left is like offended
and and i tweeted it's it's what i call
bugs bunnying where you can make you can
make a statement that should be
something they'll support but they'll
criticize so you can prove that they're
they're they're principally bankrupt
they don't actually believe what they
believe they actually care about these
things they just want to hate another
group
and i think that prison i've made i've
made several statements you know like i
think the the carhartt one
when the carhartt boycott happened i
said here's here's something if you
don't want to get vaccinated you work a
car quit
and i got criticized by the left for
saying that and i'm like
shouldn't you agree with me on that and
actually a lot of people tweeted they
were like but you know why are you
criticizing him he's right just quit
then if you don't want to work there
yeah well it's because it's not about
principles it's about being part of a
tribe that hates another tribe their
identity is based on hate that's it
and there's people on the right who are
like that for sure but it seems to be
the rule on the left well you're in like
like you said twitter i think the other
day uh two percent of americans are on
twitter and you're active on twitter and
you're like in it so you're looking at
this crazy crazy minority and it's like
oh absolutely it's gotta be loud for you
and what the algorithms want you to see
someone left a very good comment saying
that the politicians usually do go to an
island after the
fishing and that of course is fc's
clever thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time